vous les filles elena luna vous sentez
un petit peu de pression augmente et là
il ya une partie du collège de misaine
qui doit vous regardez le collège
jacques prévert donc on va y aller
tranquillement 1
black's on vous a confié commission
parce qu'on aime donner la parole aux
jeunes dans cette matinale en direct de
nous dire ce que vous aimez ce que vous
détestez puis et puis on vous a demandé
un petit coup de coeur et le coup de
coeur il concerne quoi il ya l'ena léger
vidéo les jeux vidéo
d'accord ok pourquoi tu as choisi les
baies du jeu vidéo nous avons changé jeu
vidéo car nous aimons ça et c'est décidé
tu peux y aller tranquille je peux y
aller tranquille il ya c'est toi qui
parle donc c'est toi qui choisis jeu
vidéo voici dix mois nous allons la
vidéo car nous aimons ça mais c'est
aussi parce qu'on voudrait mettre en
garderie pas les gens qui jouent de trop
donc c'est bien on peut en jouer un peu
pareil en pleurs j'ai pas on peut la
jouer une demi-heure une heure grand max
mais pas énormément parce qu'après on
peut devenir accro et les filles ça
serait encore mieux si vous touchez pas
le micro
voilà donc ça j'ai compris est ce que
toi tu joue aux jeux vidéo il ya l'ena
oui mais très peu ouais avec modération
françois ceyrac et vous avez des enfants
alors oui j'ai des enfants mais sans
grandes maintenant ouais ouais mon âge
pas de jouer un lapereau chance à marier
aussi on est tous un peu pareil vous
dominical rivière je crois bien que
c'est la même chose à la maison
bon ben voilà donc on est tous pareils
finalement on a envie de jouer mais vous
vous êtes vraiment intéressé à vos
copains et à vos copines comme commandes
et là vous vous avez interrogé mois moon
a rencontré sept élèves de tous les
niveaux
je fais pas pour sa fin une petite
savoir s'ils sont vraiment accroché
vidéo
d'accord il ya eu des résultats oui
le résultat c'est que la plupart c'est
qu'il passe une heure et demi et 4
heures par jour c'est beaucoup oui plus
ni quatre heures par jour mais il ya une
élève qui nous a dit une élève de 6e qui
nous a dit qu elle joué six et huit
heures par jour donc pas parce qu'on a
compris ck faisait pas beaucoup ses
devoirs
[Rires]
élève de qui en troisième les week-ends
et pendant les vacances elle passe dix
heures par jour mais avec des pauses une
vraie addiction ce que c'est que le mot
addiction au profit ouais ça vous parle
quand je dis addiction à dire que on est
on est accro à oui à un jeu ça devient
presque une maladie dont tu crois pas
donc ce que tu en penses toi
luna oui oui non je dis ça parce que je
sais que vous avez enquêté un tout petit
peu parce que pour ne rien vous cacher
vous quand même savoir que nos enfants
nous on fait des petites chroniques
superbe c'est comme à l'école et puis
voilà on va délivrer un petit peu le
secret de cette chronique c'est
important qu'ils arrivent aussi avec des
textes qu'ils ont travaillé à l'école
parce que tu le disait fort justement
tout à l'heure il y avait là c'est toute
la classe qui a travaillé là vous êtes
toutes les deux ça fait forcément des
jalousies et nora deux autres d'ici
quelques minutes mais voilà je voulais
qu'on regarde un petit peu à cette
chronique parce que vous avez
précisément travailler là-dessus et il
ya même une question je vais vous poser
pour le coup allait marquer la
l'addiction ou jeux vidéo est elle une
maladie alors qui peut me répondre à
cette question c'est toi
luna non et oui ouais en juin 2018
l'om est l'organisation mondiale de la
santé a créé une nouvelle malle la dilce
et le trouble du jeu vidéo 7,8 cette
maladie est quand même rare ouais enfin
il existe quand même il faut le savoir
un même pour les grands on peut être
addict aux réseaux sociaux les réseaux
sociaux qui sont présents ici chez le
notaire
je le précise avec un site est très bien
fait d'ailleurs d'être française bidet
garaï on retrouve véritablement tout ce
qu'il faut savoir sur le monde des
notaires oui oui c'est un mode
d'information c'est utile même c'est
utile encore faut-il ne pas être addict
et là je me tourne vers toi jelena parce
que je sais que tu sais ce que ce que
peut être addict dix mois mais elle est
radix et on est à dix quand en général
là
mais quand c'est quand on passe 30
heures par jour par semaine je veux dire
trente ans par nos ça commençait à faire
beaucoup la whey 30 heures par semaine à
jouer on se coupe des autres donc ceux
qui sont adeptes mais ce couple d autres
exemples là on ne mange plus je dors ne
dort plus et ne peut pas s'arrêter de
jouer les habits les plus addicts sont
souvent les les jeunes d'accord ok
peut-être une petite solution pour se
déconnecter des écrans pour terminer
olona c'est une petite et 2 bat la
solution oui et que les parents doivent
être strict avec leurs enfants et contre
les le temps des jeux ouais vous avez
des parents toutes les deux ils vous
regardent ils vont ils vont certainement
vous regardez sur les écrans connectés
vous leur direz de se mettre sur
francesoir.fr mais ne pas trop se
connecter sur les écrans et vous me
promettez aussi de pas être trop être
connecté parce que là vous m'avez fait
une jolie chronique en couleurs mais moi
je vous ai vus arriver tout à l'heure et
françoise comme dominique l'on vit aussi
vous avez toutes les deux le portable
greffé un greffe est greffé à la fois je
vous l'avais au quotidien le portable
pas tout en soit c'est la spa ce que je
veux je voulais envoyer des messages et
mes parents à mes proches à faire avec
des photos et sinon c'est juste pour
jeunes ont braqué des messages c'est
bien il faut y aller tranquille à
voyager tranquille vous pratiquez un
sport parce que ça c'est mieux non
oui oui tu portais quand je faisais du
tennis cette année mais l'année
prochaine je vais faire la gym super en
tout cas moi je vous remercie d'avoir et
eric ne s'est pas évident françoise et
dominique alors âgée de 11 ans de venir
parler comme ça à la télévision c'est
pas forcément facile si j'osais je vous
applaudirez mais je suis tout seul donc
c'est idiot en tout cas pour revenir au
sport si vous étiez dans mon école que
je vais vous présenter les filles
l'école s'appelle anne frank est à
chalon sur saône
vous pourriez faire du vélo de la place
merci à vous les filles qui on regarde
le vélo avant d'accueillir deux autres
jeunes filles de ce collège à migennes
avec nous ce matin
[Musique]
en arrivant on s'est demandé s'il
s'agissait d'une salle de classe ou
d'une salle de sports à côté du tableau
et des pupitres des vélos bureaux sont
apparus il ya une quinzaine de jours si
l'idée peut surprendre
elle a tout de suite séduit
l'enseignante de la classe on s'est
rendu compte que demain nos enfants
d'être assis sans bouger toute la
journée alors qu'en fait c'est contraire
aux besoins de des enfants un enfant a
naturellement besoin de bouger alors on
étudie et on les enfants se
relaient sur les vélos de manière
totalement autonome toutes les 20
minutes
c'est la norme dans cette classe
flexible on y trouve différentes assises
selon les besoins des enfants
on peut s'asseoir partout partout on
peut s'asseoir sur les ballons place à
sortir les vélos bureau on va s'asseoir
aussi il ya des les galettes et puis ça
on peut s'asseoir et légale et parce que
ça fait du bien
agréable parce que on aime bien les
échos
vous travaillez pédales les enfants sont
séduits et les premiers effets positifs
se font déjà sentir chez bien au monde
arrive à te concentrer un peu et quand
tu seras tu pédales un peu c'est beau ça
a permis de canaliser certains enfants
qu'il y avait une énergie négative et
qui avaient tendance à être agressif
donc quand ils ressentent le besoin de
libérer un peu d'énergie sur les vélos à
l'initiative de l'inspection académique
et en partenariat avec la ville et le
grand chalon
l'investissement a coûté près de 4000
euros après un an d'expérimentation il
espère pouvoir l'étendre à d'autres
classes et d'autres établissements des
vélos bureaux installés dans une classe
de cm1 saône-et-loire l'expérimentation
du mieux-être en classe les deux jeunes
filles qui sont avec nous sont aussi en
classe
bonjour les filles on peut se tutoyer
aussi comme on l'a fait avec vos
camarades de jeu super mauges ap ap
après votre achat vous avez quel âge 13
ans nous irons soit zénith à un peu près
à fond là au moins dans notre tête pas
céder au collège jacques prévert c'est
sa part fait à migennes génial en classe
de quatrième essai ça les copines
électeurs regardent vous avez la
pression on va se détendre quand même
vous avez choisi de nous parler de quel
sujet le mode challenge vous tourner
vers franchise vous connaissez le
challenge une idée mais j'apprends je
suis impatient permet tous impatients
c'est quoi ça pourquoi avoir choisi ce
sujet des mois nous avons choisi de
parler du monde nouveau challenge car il
y les actuels ils touchent beaucoup de
personnes et nous voulons expliquer ce
qu'est vraiment ce challenge pour que
personne se fasse prendre est d'accord
c'est dire tu peux me dire toi ce que
c'est que le boccia la nuit et vous
envoie un message sur téléphone portable
et ça circule le plus particulièrement
sur what's up
ouais tu peux parler un peu plus fort et
sert à effrayer les personnes qui
comptaient donc concrètement la
toussaint téléphone portable ici même
vous je le sais les filles je les ai vus
tout allonger les mêmes confisquer les
téléphones portables
quelques minutes avant les missiles en
basque et ça ça n'arrêtait pas
on peut recevoir ça sur son téléphone
portable donc ok j'ai compris tu es
moment c'est une femme effrayante elle a
des yeux globuleux à ce pouvoir est
inquiétant et chantant et des cheveux
gras elle a aussi des pattes d'oiseaux
là vous avez passez à l'écomusée du val
de saône encore elle a été créée par un
artiste japonais qui s'appelle mme
heater ayachi il a créé cette statue
pour ça tu qu'on voit simplement une
société c'est parce que l'image se passe
de commentaires quand même a les cheveux
bizarres des pâtes étrange fait un mix
entre un animal et puis une personne
donc ça ça peut arriver sur son portable
d'accord c'est que là j'ai bien compris
qu'est ce que demande momo dans ce
challenge que l'on peut recevoir sur son
téléphone portable des mois elle va vous
lancer des défis dangereux et que vous
serez obligés de faire sinon et vous
menacera de dévoiler les pages hanté
quoi vos informations personnelles
ouais ou de faire du mal à un manque de
votre famille et si vous acceptez faut
lui envoyer des photos en guise de
preuve
rouleau ça fait rire cet effet c'est
plutôt bon signe
ce qu'on a créé ce challenge et qu'il a
créé et finalement tu sais a été créée
en fin juillet 2018 en amérique du sud
par des personnes qui cherchent et free
que cherche quoi effrayer à effrayer
d'accord ok d'accord
finalement ça a des problèmes forcément
si on reçoit sur son portable c'est pas
très très gentil ça fait pas mal de
conséquence va recevoir un message de
moments peuvent vous angoisser mais ça
peut être plus grave y'a une jeune fille
de 12 ans en argentine et un garçon de
14 ans france qui se sont suicidés à
nouveau challenge
oui parce que là je souris mais quand
même seconde c'est un peu plus grave et
voilà pourquoi on voulait vous en parlez
aussi parce qu'il a certainement les
dents cet écran des parents des grands
parents
nous sommes tous ici autour de cette
table est franchement moi je ne
connaissais pas le moment de cela non
plus mais y at-il une antidote
voilà ça c'est ma remède il ya quelque
chose donc pour éviter ça ben en fait il
faut pas contacté non parce que il faut
pas répondre en fait oui tout ça sinon
elles peuvent ainsi elle peut vous
influencer à faire des mauvaises actions
nom est tu sais tu sais toi pourquoi en
fait momo a été créé pourquoi ils font
ça et oui pour faire taire c'est
certainement pour faire peur en tout cas
c'est certainement aussi pour faire le
buzz parce qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde
fait le buzz donc évidemment pour faire
aussi des mauvaises blagues cc voilà
puis pour pirater peut-être le contenu
du téléphone aussi il faut faire
attention les filles 1 oui pas répondre
à n'importe qui non vous me promettez
attention bon c'est une seule chose que
vous pouvez me promettre c'est sa
moralité attention réseaux sociaux ouais
vous